what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data
if this is your first time here my name
is richard and this is the channel where
we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
today we're going to talk about random
forests so
this is the amazon rainforest it's one
of the most well-known forests in the
world
it stretches across a few different
countries in south america
but most of it's in brazil this is the
crooked forest
it's in poland and i must say i have
never seen pine trees that look like
that
like upside down question mark kind of
things that's amazing i didn't even know
that was possible
then this is the goblin forest this
one's located in new zealand
and legend has it this one is full of
orcs who
right now as we speak they're plotting
their way into middle earth so they can
commit a horrible series of
devious village raids i'm sorry that was
just too easy
so in all seriousness random forests are
probably
my personal favorite machine learning
algorithm of all time
and they are one of the most popular
ones overall but they're not magical
they are not some tool that you can just
throw at any possible problem and then
bam profit they do have a reputation for
not
quite being a black box sort of thing
that something like a neural network is
but being significantly less
interpretable than something like a
regression model
or even a decision tree more on that
shortly because random forests can still
be one of the most interpretable of the
machine learning methods
at least in the context of explaining
the work that you've done to
non-technical audiences
now as a disclaimer i'm going to give a
brief overview of what exactly
random forests are but this is not a
video to provide all of the detailed
methodology behind them
that's probably the subject for a
different video
for now i'll have a link in the
description to a video by statquest with
josh starner
i think his video does a really nice job
of breaking random forests down
and i'll also provide a link in the
description to some documentation
by the guys who wrote the modern
implementation of the random forest
algorithm
the focus of this video is on the
practical instances in which random
forests can help you out
as well as when they may miss the mark a
little bit and we're going to talk about
this within the context of two
separate goals and those are inference
and prediction
now if you're unfamiliar with the
distinction between these two terms
i did a video on this topic i'll have a
card for it up above
as well as a link in the description to
that too so for those of you who are
totally unfamiliar with random forests
here's a short overview the key building
block of a random forest classifier
is the decision tree and these are a
classic method
for classification or regression
problems but in particular
these enjoy a little bit of popularity
just because they're super easy to
interpret
here's an example of a decision tree on
the right and the decision we're trying
to make here is
play tennis or not you got various
decisions that you make at each node
and overall you end up with something
that's totally clear and
very easy to understand even to a
non-technical audience
for example let's start at the top we
ask what the weather outlook is
let's suppose it's sunny you go down the
tree
you ask what the humidity is if it's
high
we say no we're not going to play tennis
if it's normal
we say yes we are going to play tennis
and so on and so forth
well the problem with decision trees
though is that they tend to have high
variance
that is they tend to overfit to the
training set and then they don't
generalize very well
random forests attempt to correct that
problem by
ensembling over many different trees
you create a bootstrapped dataset
retaining only a subset of all the
available variables
then you fit a decision tree based on
that data set
and that tree like any other provides
the rules for predicting the outcome
then repeat that process many times and
you tally up the votes
for what the individual trees are
predicting your outcome to be
the outcome with the most votes at the
end is the random forest's prediction
so at the end of the day you've got a
robust and very nicely performing
classifier that doesn't suffer from the
individual decision trees overfitting
problem
now one awesome feature of random
forests is that they also provide you a
ranking of the importance of all your
variables
then you can generate a variable
importance plot which looks like this
now this is basically telling us rm is
the most
important feature followed by lstat
followed by
dis and so on and so forth now let's
just pretend for a second that you're
working on a project and your goal is
inference that is you want to understand
the variables
that have the highest impact on the
response well guess what
the variable importance plot from a
random forest will help you in that goal
that variable importance plot we just
generated based on this data
tells us that by a fairly wide margin rm
and lstat are the two most important
features in this data
now you might be saying at this point
but random forests aren't interpretable
the same
way that a regression model is you would
be correct
however here's what's important to
understand so
all models whether they're statistical
or machine learning
carry with them certain assumptions and
they're going to have
certain advantages and disadvantages
here's just an example
regression models are only equipped to
detect
linear relationships decision trees in
random forests on the other hand
can detect non-linear relationships now
let's say you ran a regression model
and you found that rm was the most
important variable
then you ran a random forest you created
this variable importance plot
and it's also telling you that rm is the
most important variable
well from a practical standpoint you
have a lot of evidence now that that
is a very robust result because now two
different models which are
very different are effectively giving
you back the same finding
but then let's just say you ran that
regression model and it told you
age was the single most important
variable well age is the eighth variable
down the list in the variable importance
plot from the random forest
so you might just have learned something
that prevented you from making
too strong of a conclusion about the
impact age
actually has on your response so i'm
gonna level with all of you
and say random forest is actually a
really helpful tool for inference
and not just for prediction now you may
say it's still kind of like a black box
and most people don't understand the
math behind it
and you'd mostly be right but i would
tell you that just from my own personal
experience
most people do intuitively get the idea
behind a decision tree
and then it's fairly easy to explain
after that
that a random forest is essentially just
an ensemble of various different
decision trees
using re-samples of your data not
everyone will understand the math the
way that they might with regression
models
but i'll take explaining that logic any
day over explaining neural networks to
non-technical types
so now that i've hopefully convinced you
that random forests can
be pretty useful from the standpoint of
inference let's come back and talk about
the conditions when they work really
well
as well as when they don't work quite so
well for starters
one good point about random forests is
they're not the most
sensitive to outliers now i think it's
unfair to just say
outright that they're robust to outliers
because that's maybe a little too strong
of a statement
but the intuition for this is in the
base learner of the random forest
that is the decision tree so in the
fitting process for these
outliers typically get isolated into
pretty small leaves of the tree
and then decision trees operate locally
so what you end up with
is an algorithm that isn't totally
robust necessarily
but because of that combination of two
effects where you have the multiple
trees and aggregation across them
as well as the local modeling that
occurs just the design of the algorithm
makes it so that it's not
as dramatically impacted by outliers as
some others are
another positive of random forest is
that the algorithm is pretty stable
meaning if you add a small amount of new
data you're very unlikely to get
radically different results
either in the variable importance
rankings or the predictions
and this should make sense on an
intuitive level because while the new
data will affect
trees on an individual level once you
start ensembling over a number of trees
particularly over a number of trees
which aren't even going to be affected
by the new data at all
you're just not going to change the
overall forest all that much
another good feature about random
forests is they can deal with missing
data
and there are two distinct methods they
have for doing so
option one is really straightforward if
you have missing continuous data
it fills it in with the median for that
class
then if you have missing categorical
data it fills it in with the most common
level for that class
that's it option two is a little better
basically it does a rough fill-in of the
missing values
then it runs the forest then it computes
the proximity weighted
average in the case of continuous
variables or the proximity weighted
most frequent non-missing value for
categorical variables
this process is repeated several times
usually only about four to six
times more on this and a link in the
description from leo bremen and adele
cutler
who are the inventors of the modern
random forest algorithm
all of that to say random forests do
have solid ways of estimating missing
data
and you're probably going to get pretty
good performance even if that's a
problem that you're facing with your
data
and just as a side note and little known
fact because the random forest can
calculate proximities between
observations it can be used for
unsupervised clustering
and again this is detailed more by the
creators of the algorithm and that link
is in the description
also in the description i'll include a
link to an abstract on this very
application
but it's just another example of how it
is not appropriate to think of random
forest as just another black box
classification method
that's a common misconception that i
think really sells short
how beautiful and how powerful the
algorithm is
now obviously random forests are not
perfect and they do come with some
shortcomings
namely for one thing random forests are
more memory intensive
and they're going to take longer to
train and make predictions with
compared to decision trees or even some
other machine learning algorithms
intuitively that should make sense
random forests do involve
many trees so we would expect them to
take longer than just one tree
this should not be much of a problem as
far as your number of covariates is
concerned
but this can start to creep up and
become a problem if you have a data set
with a lot of observations
then also the approach of using random
forests for variable importance
is not perfect either and in fact there
are a couple things which can trip this
up by causing bias one of those is when
you have a data set that has a mix of
continuous predictors as well as
categorical predictors
particularly when those categorical
predictors have a fairly small number of
levels
well in this instance the random forest
variable importance
is going to be biased in favor of
categorical variables with more levels
the other instance is when you have some
predictors that are heavily correlated
this is going to cause you some problems
in particular
it's probably going to make it so that
some variables appear important when in
reality
they're not luckily there is a technique
for mitigating this problem
and it's through growing unbiased
conditional inference trees
as usual links to all that fun stuff in
the description
and there's ways to implement this
approach in r you can use the c
forest function from the party package
the downside is though let's just say
this approach is
not the fastest car on the race track if
you get what i mean
so hopefully by now you get the idea
with random forests
they're a beautiful algorithm and i've
personally had a great experience with
them
no matter what i was trying to do
whether it was confirming a pre-existing
hypothesis about
important variables maybe it was
classifying a test set
i just had a great time with them but
like anything they're not perfect
and hopefully now that you've watched
this video you have an idea of when
they're well suited for the problem and
when they're not
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it and you'd like to support my
work the most helpful thing that you
could do for me would be to share this
video
otherwise at least consider smashing the
like button
and also let me know down below when
you've used random forests and how
they've worked for you
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data